bonjour monsieur comment allez-vous
le banane
[Rires]
Louis XIV était-il français j'avoue je
n'aurais jamais imaginé posé une telle
question lorsqu'enfant je lisais
Alexandre Dumas ou que j'apprenais à
l'école que nos ancêtres étaient les
Gaulois Louis XIV était-il français j'ai
découvert cette affiche Affiche publiée
sous l'égide de la République française
via le ministre de la culture c'est fou
et il écrit tous ces étrangers qui ont
fait l'histoire de France
[Musique]
sa grand-mère était autrichienne sa mère
espagnole si je devine bien ce message
qui n'est pas subliminal Louis XIV est
donc un étranger nous en sommes là en
l'an de grâce 2023 Louis XIV n'est pas
un Français de souche que nous est-il
arrivé qu'avons-nous fait pour mériter
ça qu'elle dérèglement s'est-il produit
dans nos esprits dans nos cœurs dans nos
vies pour que des Petits Hommes Gris du
ministère écrivent sur les murs du pays
des choses aussi sautes
[Musique]
le ministère de la Culture a donc trouvé
les mots qui collent à l'époque j'ai
bien compris nous sommes tous des
immigrés un peu lent à la contredette
Valérie il est dur à la dur à la détente
pour moi Sylvio Berlusconi c'est un
homme authentique comme homme politique
ou président du Milan AC c'est un
exemple pour nous pour toutes les
personnes qui le représentent
[Musique]
le convoi funéraire est accueilli par
des acclamations
[Applaudissements]
l'agence santé publique France a décidé
de lancer une campagne une prévention et
de sensibilisation avec des affiches
placardées dans l'espace public qui
traitent de maladie sexuellement
transmissibles de contraception ou
encore de consentement comment savoir si
elle a toujours envie quand on fait
l'amour aucun représentant du
gouvernement français seul l'ambassadeur
s'est déplacé on retrouve d'anciens
adversaires et des chefs d'État comme sa
dernière alliée Georgia Melun très ému
pendant la cérémonie la chef du
gouvernement italien a insisté pour
organiser une journée de deuil national
demain après ces funérailles pas du goût
de toutes les opposition comme le montre
cette une du Corriere de la Serra un
adieu entre douleur épogénique les
messages que certains ont trouvé
choquants et qui s'insurgent de voir que
ces affiches puissent être vu de tous y
compris de jeunes enfants il faut
arrêter pour laisser les enfants
tranquilles une campagne de
sensibilisation diffusée dans l'espace
public choc des parents faut-il la
retirer il a fait plus de bien que de
mal il mérite son hommage
dans de telles occasions rendons hommage
à l'homme c'est la seule chose à faire
et un petit détail Mac qui nous a pas
échappé qui vous a un peu perturbé petit
petit vous allez la voir cette petite
statue avec un détail je suis sûr qu'il
vous saute également aux yeux à ce que
c'est un truc dans les mains c'est ça
voilà il a un truc dans les mains il est
un peu un truc dans le slip aussi qui
prend un placement c'est inadmissible
que des enfants de 7 ans c'est bon c'est
bon
ça ça fait beaucoup parler sur les
réseaux sociaux et notamment en
Argentine alors c'est un choix assumé ce
paquet dans le slip par l'artiste
Mercedes Saval qui explique que il
s'agit de football et que quand il
s'agit de football les supporters
demandent toujours aux joueurs et à
l'entraîneur de montrer qu'ils en ont
voilà
ambiance spéciale pour l'anniversaire de
Kanye West au menu des sushis disposés
sur le corps d'une femme tout cela sous
les yeux de la fille du rappeur North
neuf ans qui préfère le plateau
indignation sur les réseaux sociaux
cette pratique appelée new temori est
originaire du Japon où elle est aussi
jugée dégradante elle serait née à
l'époque des samouraïs qui fêtaient leur
victoire militaire non mais attends
là là je me dis je suis tombé ou quoi
c'est grave le fond Marianne c'était son
idée mais depuis les premières
révélations Marlène Schiappa s'était
fait discrète la voici sous serment pour
répondre sénateurs sur la gestion de ce
fond au cœur d'une commission d'enquête
sénatoriale et d'une information
judiciaire du parquet national financier
notamment pour détournement de fonds
publics pour la ministre ce n'est pas
elle mais les membres de son cabinet et
les gestionnaires du fond Marianne qui
ont choisi les lauréats le président de
la commission d'enquête sagace alors
continuez vous vraiment
à daigner toute responsabilité dans ce
fiasco Marlène Schiappa maintient sa
version je redis que je n'avais pas
d'implication personnelle que je n'ai
pas soutenu de dossier en particulier je
le redis très clairement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme vous voyez Caroline va de mieux en
mieux est-ce que tu entends la mer avec
les algues
avec vous j'ai pas en tête la totalité
des noms ou des visages des gens qui ont
pris part à ce projet j'ai pas souvenir
de les avoir reçus mais ça veut pas dire
que ça soit impossible moi j'ai pas
souvenir je n'avais aucun souvenir très
sincèrement monsieur le Président j'en
ai pas souvenir je n'ai pas souvenir je
ne peux pas vous répondre j'en ai pas de
souvenir je ne savais pas je n'ai pas
connaissance manifestement j'en ai pas
souvenir résultat elle est énervée de
Monsieur à la moustache ce qu'on vous
dit Madame c'est ce que vous savez
comment vous oubliez pas tout de votre
vie quand même vous savez quoi je vais
l'utiliser pour le reste du jeu
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je vous appelle
mais vous m'avez appelé non non
c'est moi qui vous appelle
[Musique]
Marlène je sais pas l'histoire d'une
femme qui ne se souvenait de rien en
balade avec myocchi et comme vous pouvez
le voir c'est mieux qui choisit le
chemin pas moi c'est normal parce que
c'est sûrement c'est sa balade